the experience was wonderful I feel like  I found out a lot about myself not just  the gymnastics but snow but like normal  smooth Simone biles reveals Dancing with  the Stars caused her to lose her abs  telling us weekly quote dance helps keep  me in shape but I've lost my six-pack  I'm not as toned the couple leaving  right now is Simone and Sasha Monday  night's elimination shocked us all et  caught up with the gymnasts backstage  just after the show this isn't my  element if you were gymnastics I'd like  you're know what Simone you better get  back in the gym but I don't know how to  dance in heels this was legs something I  was still tripping yesterday she  literally has been a dream come true to  work with that she's grown so much as a  person and I wish she was in that final  I wish she won this whole competition  and I wish the best for I'm gonna be  there cheering her on at the next  Olympics with a huge sign saying go  small nothing golden giggles  [Music]